all right i wanted to mention this too
this is interesting a story
from msn it says a school district in
southwest missouri is bringing back a
measure it last resorted to over two
decades ago to address disciplinary
problems
that is spanking students classes
started monday for the 1900 students in
classville
um r-4 school district about an hour
west of branson and some 15 miles from
the arkansas border during open house
families were notified that the school
board had adopted a policy in june
allowing physical force as a method of
correcting student behavior
parents were handed forms to specify
whether they authorized the school to
use a paddle on their child
formerly known as
corporal punishment the disciplinary
measure usually involves spank striking
students on the buttocks with a wooden
paddle
in casseville staff members will employ
reasonable physical force without a
chance of bodily injury or harm in the
presence of a witness this is according
to the new policy
now what exactly constitutes reasonable
physical force is unclear but that's
what they're going to do now
this is interesting to me because it
kind of again highlights
some of the fundamental problems with
the school system the public school
system
um it's true
that there's a total lack of discipline
in the school system
kids don't respect their teachers or the
administrators
they don't care about the punishments
suspension in particular is a is a
really i think this is where the
paddling idea originally came from is
that they were looking for
another form of punishment instead of
suspension
and that makes sense in a certain way
because suspense suspension is a is a
particularly stupid form of punishment
because the kinds of kids who get
suspended
are also the kinds of kids who love
nothing more than to stay home from
school
and they're likely to be the kinds of
kids whose parents aren't going to hold
them accountable at home so by
suspending them you're not really
accomplishing anything suspension only
works as a disciplinary tool if the
child being suspended number one wants
to come to school and so you're taking
something away from him that he wants
and two
has parents who will react with
appropriately severe
you know with with appropriate severity
to their child being suspended in the
first place
so if you need both of those criteria to
be met in order for the suspension
to work as a punishment
but usually
um neither of the criteria are met
so what are you left with
they don't really expel kids anymore
unless they're found guilty of
misgendering in which case we make you
know then you can toss them out
there's detention but that only goes so
far and uh what if a kid refuses to show
up to detention what do you do
this is the kind of hopeless
situation that lots of teachers and
administrators are in there's like
there's nothing they can do the kids are
not listening
they don't care they have no respect
um they have no you know they haven't
been raised to respect their elders or
anything like that so just what are you
supposed to do with them
and it's what makes you think well maybe
it's time to introduce corporal
punishment as another option
but then here
here comes another complication because
if i'm a parent
sending my kid to public school
in the year 2022
i am not going to be okay with paddling
because there's no way in hell that i
trust the teachers or administrators to
dole out a punishment like that
appropriately or responsibly i just
don't trust them
and so when you're using physical force
in that way and you're authorizing
another adult a stranger you have to
really trust there's to be a lot of
trust there
but i'm not going to have that kind of
trust
in any of the adults working in the
school system right now i just don't
trust you
so no stranger especially not one in
public schools laying a hand on my kid i
don't trust them i don't trust any adult
with that especially not government
workers in a government
in the government school system
yeah i'm not gonna i'm not gonna entrust
government employees
to
physically punish my child no
this is the conundrum then that you deal
with uh the lacks discipline doesn't
work
but harsher discipline requires a
certain amount of trust between school
and parent and that trust doesn't exist
and largely that's the fault of the
schools because they've destroyed all
that trust
[Music]
so what's the answer
well i'll tell you what the answer is
get your kid out of the public school
system that's the answer
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast